[Music]
so i'm gonna turn it over to tom in
chicago he can walk us through what's
been going on hey tom what's up man
oh we're hanging in there good deal so
um kelly uh sent me a note ahead of time
on this call so i could sit down with an
expert which i spent some time with to
make sure that i was able to serve you
guys the best we can
um
but i wanna hear your story just um as
as much as you feel
that you can share with us and we'll go
from there
sure um so yeah thanks for talking with
us so we found out a few weeks ago that
a extended relative has been
uh sexually molesting our six-year-old
daughter
um that person has now been arrested so
our question for you is what
what does the next
days weeks months years look like for
our daughter and how can we best help us
oh man so welcome me back how'd y'all
figure number one i
i mean this is every parent's worst
nightmare right and
i guess as the father of a six-year-old
girl my heart's broken for you and
um
i'd hug you if you were sitting here so
just from your city to my city know that
i love you and i'm sorry this happened
um
jeez so
how how did y'all what with you how you
found out what's what's happened since
then
yeah the short version was my wife um
observed it in action
and observed what was happening
um we found out it's been going on for
several months
and then we
involved the authorities at that point
and then good for you
thank you good for you man
yeah there's been there has been some
negative feedback from other family
members on that yeah we'll screw them
they don't get a vote
yeah forget them if you ever doubt that
once just call me
and i'll just say screw them they don't
get a vote
thank you the worst
absolute the worst unbelievable
it's disgusting and hey i hate the fact
i'd hate everything about this man
so um did y'all so your wife witnesses
this obviously she i'm assuming she flew
into a rage and stopped everything
um
not a rage she pulled the kids out of
the situation um because our younger son
was there at the time it was a
probably fairly typical of these sort of
situations where they were sitting on a
chair yeah and watching a you know
perfectly fine video and
the person put his hands down inside
yeah her pants yep um so she separated
them started talking to people and our
daughter after a little bit did say you
know guess what's had been happening
they've been going on for a while yeah
and then
my wife talked to the person
who after lying did say yes it did
happen
um at that point my wife removed
everyone from the home that the
family members home and then um
we came home or she came home we talked
about who we call involved involve the
authorities at that point
gotcha
well man i am so proud of you all for
listening to your daughter
and believing your daughter obviously
your wife saw this and for calling the
police um that already is step one
towards healing
okay
um did y'all go through
the rigamaroo the forensic interview the
nurse examinations y'all go through all
that yes yeah that happened within a few
days afterwards and then there was no
nothing else
physically she's fine
okay
um for people who
don't know
when you call the police they'll not
they'll normally go to a forensic
interview or somebody um some sort of
psychologist or sometimes a detective
will
walk through an interview sometimes it's
done in play therapy sometimes it's done
in a really not great way um just in an
office with big fluorescent lights and
it's really scary and intimidating for a
six-year-old but that's when they really
dig in and get to the bottom what
happened and then there's often a
nurse's examination which is a really
invasive but very important physical
examination to see if there's any you
know
any tearing any any sort of physical
uh
issues here right
and here's what i'll tell you that feels
like you can exhale a tiny bit when
those things are over
um i don't want you to underestimate
what a huge
shape-shifter impact that was for your
daughter
okay
those things sometimes come up 15 or 20
years later when she breaks her arm and
needs to go to the doctor and she won't
go
or when she's struggling with anxiety
and won't go talk to a counselor because
the whole process feels like
it's all wrapped up into this one thing
you know what i'm saying
okay
so
what has been the next steps have you
all called somebody have you all started
talking to somebody what's been the next
steps or is it just kind of been a
freeze moment
um a little bit initial is the freeze
moment um
we you know just kind of we had to
uh yeah freeze from that point and then
we started talk we've talked to our
pastor and his wife who've been very
helpful
some other close friends and then we
have talked to a couple different
counselors
okay well you know
been very helpful from their different
points of views
um the real thing we've been dialing
down on which our pastor gave us this
device is really just work on connecting
with
our kids okay um you know not not
specifically our daughter but both of
them yeah
um all right i'm gonna be real
straightforward here okay
and i'm assuming you're a pastor so
you're a person of faith
yes all right so i'm speaking as um
somebody on your team i'm person to
faith too okay not a big chunk of our
listeners aren't that's fine i i want
you to hear that i'm not coming at you
but i'm saying this sitting on the pew
next to you okay
um i'm actually not gonna give you the
ins and outs of what to do with your
daughter
here's why
this is not a moment for armchair
quarterback in this thing
this isn't a moment for googling this is
not a moment for pastors this is not a
moment for guidance counselors this
isn't a moment for asking people their
quote unquote wisdom
this is a stop the presses find a
trauma-focused cognitive behavioral
therapist a tfcbt therapist in your
community
and work a plan
and there's plans called seeking safety
there's some really extraordinary
processes with a trained professional
what i don't want you to do is to think
we can just do some things
and then it will be cool and we'll just
keep checking in with such and such your
pastor actually gave you some great
advice which is rarely the case these
days unfortunately
um you got some great advice
connection's important
but that is
that's at the periphery okay
that is like if you think of a of
somebody who's scuba diving and they
need oxygen and then they need the tank
and then they need the boat
your pastor just told you to put gas in
the boat right
it's peripheral to the person at the
bottom of the ocean right now okay
um
your daughter over time with a therapist
is gonna here's what she's gonna relearn
she's gonna re-learn
what good touches
what safety feels like
that a a despicable evil thing happened
to her but she's not despicable or evil
that somebody committed a great shameful
evil act against her but she's not
shameful her body's not shameful
sexual intimacy when she's married in
down the road is not shameful
and somebody's gonna have to walk her
through this and she is six
okay
here's what that looks like they're
gonna teach her body to
not spin up on her when somebody begins
to invade her space and there's just a
process to that what i'll tell you is on
the back end of the process
the healing rate is is really
extraordinary it's pretty it's actually
it's unbelievable if you get with the
right person
teaching a six-year-old how to reclaim
autonomy of their body after someone has
taken it from them particularly somebody
that they trusted it's just hard
it's hard
and so um i don't want a bad mouth
preachers i don't want a bad mouth i'm
not doing that i'm just saying this is
one of those moments you don't try to
change the oil in your driveway on this
one you go to a
the dealer mechanic on this one and get
the right work done okay
um
here's the
some people will say i don't have people
in my area i don't have
whatever
then you drive
you figure it out um somebody works goes
to part-time for a year or six months
and we drive or we get hotel and we
figure this thing out this is really
hard okay
um here's the second or third or i don't
even know what number we're on here um
inside your house
when your kid talks about this has she
brought it up ever has it come up
no
um
no not really she's talked about the
person who did it um and not in the not
in a negative context but more like hey
i'd like to go do this with this person
or they used to do this with me yes okay
i'm gonna tell you some really hard
stuff right now okay
one of the great evils of
sexual abuse with children
is being able to
toggle apart to pull apart that felt
good
with this was wrong
you know what i mean
it's this it's um when you the first
time i heard an eight-year-old say
explain to me how she liked what was
happening like i wa like that was one of
the only times i've ever felt close to
physically vomiting in a conversation
with a kid it was it's brutal okay
and so yes there's gonna be this weird
hey can i go back and see
because i don't fully grasp the depth of
what has happened to me right
right and
so you here's an important thing i need
you to put in your back pocket and your
wife and anybody else you trust and love
with your kid conversations will come up
over time
and
anything other
you don't this is not for fixing your
kid
you can't fix anything here what we're
looking for is i want you to say i see
you i hear you
so when it comes up did you know that
this happened to me
do you remember when so and so did x and
y and z
the response is not a list of
things we've googled or that we've got
from somebody yeah this it is
i'm so so sorry that happened to you
that should not have happened to you and
i love you
that's the answer right so we're always
going with i see you and i hear you and
your feelings are valid and what you
remember is valid i believe you not i'm
going to fix this right now in this
conversation because what she's doing
now is she's re-practicing safety who's
safe
and the person who tries to dump a bunch
of info on her a bunch of facts and this
and this and this into that six-year-old
seven-year-old nine-year-old 15 year old
little brain
is not safe okay
safe is i see you okay and here's
another heavy one that i see a lot
if you or your wife or your family
members break down when this
conversation comes up which it will
or when she says hey i want to go see so
and so i want to go see uncle whoever or
what whoever
and you go
either you break down crying or you fly
off into rage or whatever that that over
emotion is what she's gonna quickly
learn to do is to help you emotionally
regulate yourself
and that's not her job
okay
so it there is feeling sad and there's
feeling heartbroken and they're letting
her know i choose to be angry about this
because that shouldn't have happened to
you or what happened to you was wrong
and that shouldn't happen you are too
precious and too wonderful and too
important and too brilliant and too
too beautiful and too strong should
never have happened to you
there's a difference between that and
just a fit of weeping and rage and you
might have the rage you might have the
weeping i sure would
um i'm gonna
have my extreme moments with my
counselor okay i'm gonna have my extreme
moments with my group of guys that i
meet with on a regular basis those guys
can handle the weight of my friendship
in those moments a six and nine-year-old
can't what i don't want a nine-year-old
doing is saying if i talk about this it
makes daddy really sad and so i'm just
gonna talk about it because i love daddy
and i don't want to be the one making
him sad you see how that math works for
a kid
and so it's that balance of you don't
want to be a robot you want him to know
what noise this made me sad and i'm
choosing to have my heart broken here
all those things
and
i'm still in control of my body i'm
still controlling my feelings and
emotion in this house
um here's the last thing i'll ask you
um without getting in detail about the
family member
how are you man
like somebody in your family hurt your
kid like that's a hard thing to make
peace with
yeah i don't i didn't really have any i
had more of the sadness motion just see
all the weight of the situation not any
of the anger rage it will come
it will come okay be ready for it
because it will come in waves okay
um have you had a chance is this your
family member or your wife's family
member
of my wife um have you had a chance to
talk to the person
uh i had a short conversation with them
uh
an hour two before they were arrested
when they were asking me not to call the
police
okay that's good
i would recommend
of all the things i've just told you
besides seeing your kid the second most
important recommendation is i would make
sure you are constantly writing things
down that you feel that you want to say
that come to mind i wish i could have
this phone call and they'll come more
and more over time
and um
when you are about to go to sentencing
and when the your daughter gets put on a
witness stand which you probably will
all those kind of things make sure
you've got a
legacy of writing this stuff out here's
why
and your wife too if you don't it
we call i call it leakage that's a gross
counseling word but it will find its way
out and it usually find its way out in a
real inopportune time that sometimes
makes you look foolish or you look like
an idiot
like you look like the problem when
you're not you're a dad who's beside
himself because somebody hurt your baby
you know what i'm saying
so this is constant i i i i would really
recommend you and your wife get somebody
to talk to
because there's going to be the guilt
and it was your family and i can't
believe i missed this all those things
are part of the healing process that the
whole family's going to undergo here and
having a
person that would walk through that with
you would be really important
um okay so i just threw a lot at you
here's what the next few months is going
to look like you ready drum roll i have
no idea okay i have no idea
um
i know that if you get your daughter
into
some sort of tfcbt treatment program
with a therapist that you trust that's
good
um and you and your wife give her see
her and give her space and you're
connected with her
um
you let her have her feelings out loud
that the chances that she grows up to be
well and whole are very very very good
okay
um and
this will
this will
raise hell and her for years and years
and years to come it's the it's the evil
of sexual abuse and trauma
okay it's holding both of those things
very loosely right
anybody who tries to tell you well the
next two months is going to be like this
is just selling you something get away
from that person okay
don't take any outside counsel or
information and try to impose a
framework on how your daughter should be
healing right now how she should be
feeling her grief as hers and she
doesn't even know she's grieving yet
she misses special time with uncle
so-and-so
and that's so disgusting to even say out
loud but that's the reality of a
six-year-old right okay
um how's your marriage right now brother
um
as good as it's ever been it's this is
really that's it hasn't been
this is not creating any sort of stress
between us thankfully it's awesome and
good awesome
the temptation will be you all have been
really tight and having a lot of great
conversations and probably going on
walks and having moments of what do we
do now and all those kind of things that
can bring a couple together
please make sure you put a star on a day
on the calendar and you'll continue
having these at regular intervals how
are you how are we how are we doing
how's things going are we going to go
out on a date tonight are we going to
continue to do life
okay
please make sure you all continue that
thing moving forward um and again i
don't it's not going to help you i just
need to say it out loud man i'm sorry
this happened
i'm sorry thank you that's
and by the way
call me anytime you need to tell me
you need me to tell you
to screw them
sure any family member that is
there should be a race to the police
department
i'm going to call them no no no i'm
calling them let's call them together
that's the race
okay
anybody who tells you well i don't i
just don't think we should press charges
or um are we sure anybody who says that
is done
yeah you got it
yep and that might be really hard it
might be your wife's parents
that might be her other siblings and
they are opting out of your life if they
if they make those suggestions
okay okay
i've got no quarter for that nonsense it
should be a group of people rallying
around
a um hurting six-year-old little girl
not trying to protect and a
scumbag
gosh man somebody who's got a lot of
challenges anything i can help you else
with brother i feel like i talked at you
a lot anything i can help with ma'am
no i think that has been very helpful to
give us a pathway to what we should be
doing and in touch with the right
counselors okay
um if you need something man please i'll
walk with you through this um holler at
me if you need anything
um
and just so for the general public we
are talking about creating some training
for pastors and what they say when
someone drops us on because they just
don't have that training and how what
would we say to
people who are just helpful friends and
neighbors and go-to folks in communities
what do you do what do you say when some
when a child drops us on you when a
parent comes to you
what do you say or do and somebody in
your family comes to you and says hey i
think one of our family members is
abusing children what do you do at that
point um so we may come out with some
trainings there um if you have interest
in that holler at me because i think
we're gonna need to get on that there's
just too much hurt going on and too many
people hurting kids and then people the
follow up the care that happens right
after that's just a mess man
thank you so much tom for
being brave and for having a hard
conversation and big shout out to you
and your wife for staying connected
during the season
and for loving that six-year-old little
girl